et avec nous pour en parler jean paul
huchon ancien président ps de la région
ile-de-france bonjour je vous remercie
d'être avec nous ce matin alors dans
quel état d'esprit vous êtes vous
aujourd'hui
après ce passage en force confirmé du
gouvernement suis scandalisé enfin je
veux dire il faut il faudrait avoir un
petit peu de temps pour expliquer 1
est ce que cette réforme est
indispensable d'un point de vue
financier c'est très contesté tous les
économistes sérieux disent que non que
c'est pape et c'est qu'on a le temps
sur ce point là précisément on a les
moyens de financer cette réforme des
retraites
autrement bien sûr parce que les
hypothèses de soi disant déficits n'ont
pas été confirmées par les experts
et comme en plus on ne sait pas au jour
d'aujourd'hui quelle sera la valeur du
point
comment ça fonctionnera pour ceux qui
n'ont plus de régimes spéciaux etc
on est dans un flou même pas artistique
un fléau terrible et d'ailleurs il y a
trois motions de censure ou 2030
ceinture ils sont déposés
pour des raisons qui tiennent à la
manière dont tout ça a été fait et la
méthode et l'espagne
l'hypocrisie affreuse de profiter de
cette crise sanitaire pour cacher sous
le tapis c'est ce que vous pensez le
sait pas un agenda malheureux c'est
lamentable c'est pas un agenda
malheureuse c'est une forfaiture passer
quelque chose de grave' vous trompez de
la représentation nationale vous trompez
des français et tout d'un coup vous
sortez ça comme une espèce de lapin d'un
chapeau sans avoir prévenu personne
parce que que le 49-3 abandonnés ou un
autre soit utilisé peut-être mais je ne
vois pas pourquoi le gouvernement
s'expose à des critiques mortel à turin
depuis si longtemps pour un texte qui
n'aura pas d'effet avant les années 2025
il ya absolument aucune urgence dans
cette affaire mais il ya simplement
l'obstination d'un homme ou d'un
gouvernement à passer absolument avant
les municipales qu'elle intéresse à de
mélanger toutes ces choses comme ça là
je vois bien ce qu'ils ont fait on fait
semblant de tenir un conseil des
ministres sur le coronavirus qui n'a
d'ailleurs pas beaucoup lieu d'être
puisque le travail est fait par le
ministre
tout le monde est d'accord sur ce qui
fait et c est tout d'un coup paf on
balance le 40e fois la surprise générale
en profitant des airs de l'absence des
gens qui ne sont pas là donc tout ça et
c'est vulgaire et elle est vulgaire
conséquence justement de ce passage en
force
bad est conséquente dû passer en force
et que probablement le texte sera adopté
après deux motions de censure corps ont
échoué bien sûr mais il sera adopté en
première lecture
après il faut passer au sénat au sénat
les sénateurs eux n'ont pas de 43 et
donc ils vont pouvoir débattre ray
amendes etc
ça va donc continuer à refaire perdre
beaucoup de temps tous savons et après
une fois que ça sera revenu à
l'assemblée nationale il faut une
commission mixte paritaire elle ne se
remettra jamais d'accord sur ce sujet et
donc il faudra repasser et en plus il ya
un deuxième texte la loi organique là
qui elle peut pas subir me semble-t-il
de 49,3 alors la question qui est posée
c'est à quoi ça sert de pousser les feux
et d'accélérer sur une réforme qu'on
pourrait franchement discuter des bas
après tout ils sont 350 députés
moi j'ai travaillé avec michel rocard il
a déposé le caractère froid les
journalistes le disent beaucoup que la
différence est que michel rocard et moi
on avait pas de majorité à l'assemblée
donc c'était à sac ça servait mais ça
sert pas à écraser aux aigles n'a
fonctionné qu'une seule fois c'était en
1962 sous l'ère pompidou ce qui avait
conduit son gouvernement a démissionné
mais les gaullistes avait remporté les
législatives et puis donc les revenus
oui si l'on passe ta garbi zanni
basculer les gaullistes
est ce que vous estimez vous que ce qui
s'est passé hier c'est c'est justement
une ligne de conduite anti démocratiques
comme beaucoup le dénonce au sein de
l'opposition
si les de l'arrogance de la brutalité et
en plus honnêtement c'est inutile parce
que cette loi
personne ne sait ce qui vous voyez on va
voter une loi d'une personne de cfk de
danse dit la valeur du point
ni la pénibilité ni le financement
c'est quand même extraordinaire vous
avez voté sa médiocrement ce que c'est
quand même très médiocre tout ça et je
pense que il aurait fallu il faudrait
que ils se ressaisissent et que on
décide d'aller au bout qui après tout on
va au bout ça prendra un mois deux mois
et qu'est ce que ça peut faire
honnêtement le système des retraites
n'est pas à la côte
d'ici deux mois tout ça n'a pas de sens
alors l'exécutif le gouvernement qui
s'apprête probablement remporter une
bataille donc institutionnel la bataille
dans la rue va être véritablement gagné
par cet exécutif son gouvernement
puisqu'on sait que les syndicats vont
s'organiser des probablement la semaine
prochaine on se
il faut s'attendre vraiment à des temps
difficiles pour tout le monde
vous voyez bien que en pleines élections
municipales qui déjà créé des tensions
comme on le voit à paris ou ailleurs
faire monter une mayonnaise pareil en ce
moment alors qu'il ya des problèmes
sanitaires semble-t-il grave et qui a
par ailleurs une fille économique qui se
profile et des risques de danger pour la
paix mondiale avec la ciani et cetera je
trouve ça c'est suicidaire et on est à
deux ans et demi et des présidentielles
mais et puis les restrictions en cif
face à l'épidémie de coronavirus
interdiction notamment de mobiliser
au-delà de 5000 personnes ça ça risque
aussi faisait quelques options purement
vu des mobilisations qui sont annoncés
ici on était 2
ils ont moqueur ou de mauvaise foi on
dirait on est après tout ça pour arrêter
les manifs et c'est sûr mais franchement
tout ça est tellement minable je dirais
j'ai rarement vu moi j'en ai vu des
gouvernements je peux vous dire depuis
trentaine d'années j'ai rarement vu
quelqu'un raté une réforme est un texte
à ce point là en multipliant je dirais
toutes les oppositions contre lui parce
que ne l'oublions pas signé alexander le
disait encore il ya 75 % des français
qui sont contre cette réforme
et est ce qu'on peut faire une réforme
en ayant trois quarts des français
compte je crois pas je crois pas c'est
pas une méthode de gouvernement
merci beaucoup jean paul et chiant je
rappelle que vous êtes l'ancien
président ps de la région ile de france
merci à new delhi